it was really dry it's kind of honestly
one of the driest chicken burgers I've
ever had she can bring the check I'll be
happy
this place is a train wreck and arena
might not treat her like a general
manager but Mandy's sure works like one
down the end of the dining room two
minutes I want to tell Gordon if things
don't change
nobody's gonna be here the Calumet will
close you strike me as the owner because
you're so busy every time listen you're
already in the mouth and the labs in
reception I hate them and adjust murmurs
I hate it I hate that well you see how
much amuse you do they know that you can
run this place people know we are all
incompetent remember what frustrates you
most of other two sisters vanda's a
micromanager she's very cynical she
doesn't even get up off her ass and help
if it's busy she doesn't care well this
is what makes my house payment I do and
Rena is a pansy can't stand that what is
green and good at doing cried nah
are they qualified to run this business
no they should go out and work in the
real world first and the rest of staff
your team that work under you there is
some business towards the owners has
this been building loving people are
about to explode the biggest problem at
the hotel is the ownership who are
supposed to respect ultimately doesn't
respect us and I think that makes people
really not want to be a part of this
team
the only shining light in this building
right now is you because if you weren't
here there I don't think Vanda and Rina
have a clue about how much they've
really upset their staff with their
absences and their high-handed behavior
I need to get the staff and the owners
in one room and try to get them to
communicate okay when was last time all
of you had a meeting when you first
purchased this place so nine months ago
mm-hmm we're just so burned out Gordon
so are we first of all you guys I think
you guys need to understand that we live
like among in four corner walls and we
have no escape we have we're living
there nobody made you stay and live here
you know what I think I think we know
what the problem is we stepped in their
territory and they cannot let go of
their ego here's the problem if y'all
[ __ ] you got to work I wouldn't be so
[ __ ] mad all the time I know one
thing that I come to work and I do my
job where the [ __ ] are you Monday what
kind of effect does that have on the
team when you can't get a word from your
owners it's really annoying it's it's
passive-aggressive behavior
it makes people just very um you know
they don't want to talk to you then fine
you don't want to talk to us we don't
wanna talk to you
but when they do there's attitude and
those are all that should start W to
then see that's fine I'm just I want you
are committed the housekeeping to fund s
to survey we want to know that you're
gonna be here that's the thing
I'm [ __ ] done I'm [ __ ] [ __ ] off
committed he's stupid [ __ ] you just got
here
I wrote 65 [ __ ] hours a week
sometimes 70 and I have two [ __ ] kids
I'm a single [ __ ] mom it feels like
I'm in a woman's [ __ ] prison I'm
leaving I'm dying